players who hung around too long in the
nfl peter trivia question
which is higher
the number of times brett lorenzo farve
led the league in touchdown passes or
interceptions
interceptions
[Music]
wait which one is it
okay we
hit the wrong button it's the walt walk
i thought the same thing it's a trick
question i just assumed it was
interceptions four times he led in
touchdowns three times he led
in interceptions and well the reason why
i said interceptions is is that why
would you be asking the question if it
wasn't interceptions
trick
exactly that's why i thought the same
thing oh yeah it's a setup and it wasn't
set up all right yeah uh it sets it up
very well for brett favre because that's
my first pick that that last season 2010
when
i think it was ryan longwell
jared allen
and one other guy
steve hutchinson
steve hutchinson they went down to
got on an airplane hog tied brett favre
and brought him back to minnesota they
should have left him in mississippi that
season
was
it was never going to live up to 2009
it was a disaster for him personally
because that was that whole
jen sturger thing that never would have
come to light if he wouldn't have played
that one more year
and it just ended up being a very very
regrettable season for brett favre ended
his consecutive game streak had he got
roughed up in new england that year
bloodied and had hit the turf at tcf
bank stadium it was just it was a bad
bad exit for brett favre he should have
just called it quits after that 2009 nfc
championship loss to the saints peter
i'm going to give you a little dose of
history with my first one but i'll stay
with quarterbacks and that is joe namath
in 1977
with the los angeles rams i think he
only started four games when he went
there but look his knee was ruined when
he went to the rams
uh and it was a very very ugly end for
broadway joe it's just very very strange
seeing him on the field you know out
west
rather than seeing him on the crappy
turf of shea stadium
similar
context
similar distance baltimore to san diego
the last year for for johnny unitas not
a good performance didn't play in many
games and we've talked about this before
on this program i still remember getting
the football card of johnny unitas as a
member of the chargers where they
basically took a colt's jersey and got
like a felt-tip pen
and colored it to make it look like a
chargers jersey that's how jarring it
was and it just it just shouldn't have
happened
yeah
uh here's one though i'll tell you one
that shouldn't have happened
franco harris with the seattle seahawks
oh very i mean i'll never forget
watching watching seahawks games that
year and you know how when the games
were in the kingdome
okay and you would watch those games the
lighting was always substandard
so it always looked like you were
watching a game
at the kingdom and you say will somebody
please turn the lights on
and here's frank o'hara's you know with
the same kind of uh running style i
think he only ran it like 60 or 70 times
that year but running out of bounds on a
bad team on bad turf in bad lighting
it was a bad look mike
do you remember
when franco harris was approaching jim
brown's all-time rushing record brown
was talking about coming out of
retirement and they actually did
this half-hour feats of strength show
where they did like different
and they did a 40-yard dash and jim
brown pulled up with a hamstring injury
just two steps out of it do you remember
that
i don't remember it but
i i could see it
jim brown was tormented by the
possibility of frank o'hara's catching
him because obviously jim brown walked
away with plenty of gas left in the tank
here's one that uh
i got a couple more
chris carter had one final season
with the miami dolphins which was as
forgettable a final season as anyone
could ever have and i just think it's
stubbornness and i don't i don't have a
problem with it great athlete hall of
famer
vikings were ready to move on he wasn't
2002 with the dolphins he had i think
single-digit catches for the year and i
remember they played the vikings that
year it was a nationally televised game
and there's just carter standing on the
sideline it's like
why but i think some guys need that they
need that closure they need to
understand that it's that the game's
moved on that they're no longer what
they were and otherwise you have that
regret that never goes away that i could
have played one more year you did it and
you realized no you couldn't and you
shouldn't have done it
i'm going to give you one that until i
you know i knew we were going to do this
segment and i started looking around i
had totally forgotten
thurman thomas's
last cup of coffee in the nfl the miami
dolphins now what was so weird about
that mike okay joe namath went to the
rams that has no
who who cares not who cares but
you know that's that's across the
country it's in the other conference all
that johnny united goes to the chargers
that's a thousand three thousand miles
away but
when when thurman thomas went to one of
the arch rivals the buffalo bills
it was just very strange it was almost
like a vengeance signing
and and when he signed there it was
clear that it was over because he had
what 100 or 200 yards rushing and then
he just sort of faded away
after that
that was really one of the weird ones
that i felt uh that you know just it
just didn't fit at the time but i think
that's part of the reason why the
thurman thomas probably wanted to do it
he wanted to say to the bill see
somebody still wants me
last one for me chris carter's former
protege in minnesota randy moss now he
had that weird 2010 season where he was
with the patriots he started to complain
publicly about how he didn't think he
was going to get a new contract they
trade him to the vikings for a third
round pick after three games brad
childress calls him a programmatic
non-fit which i think is the only time
in the history of civilization that term
has been used other than just now and uh
cuts him
and then the titans claim him on waivers
and he didn't do anything and then he's
out of football in 2011 and he comes
back and plays for the 49ers in 2012 and
almost wins a super bowl on a team to
which he contributed very very very
little he just should have stayed out he
would have been in the hall of fame a
year or two earlier but uh that that and
i'm i'm taking a liberty here and i'm
kind of wedging the end of 2010 on to it
but that last phase of randy moss's
career was just very bizarre peter
yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna just add
one little note in here and it isn't
about the last year a guy played it's
about the last year a guy didn't play
and i remember being in training camp
with the denver broncos in one of mike
shanahan's last years
when
jerry rice i think he was 42 or maybe 43
was in training camp trying to win a job
with the denver broncos
and i remember watching a practice one
afternoon and i watched him being man
covered by a free agent cornerback from
bowling green
and on two snaps in a row this guy clung
to jerry rice who was running as fast as
he could to try to get away from this
kid who was half his age
and a few days later literally a few
days later the broncos and rice
announced that either he was retiring or
i forget what the announcement was but
it was it was jarring
to see a free agent corner in the early
days of training camp
basically winning battles with the great
jerry rice but
mike it ends for all of them sooner or
later
and i'm not being critical and we're not
intending to to throw shade at these
guys the the topic is who stayed one
year too long but it's better to stay
one year too long and find out than to
constantly have that doubt that you
could have done it i wonder if drew
brees is going through that right now as
we continue to wonder what his next move
is is he thinking after seeing what tom
brady did last year i can do it one more
year and if i don't i'm going to regret
it for the rest of my life you know and
i think you you were the first one to to
tell me this at some point over the past
few years the brett favre
motivation to come back
and keep going was the phil sims advice
and i know chris and i have talked about
it hey keep playing until they rip the
uniform off of you well if you stink in
your last year they're going to rip the
uniform off of you
yeah and i think
it brees's case is weird mike
um
you know recently somebody in in new
orleans who i trust said basically
there's nothing there don't worry about
it you know in due time basically
well i mean
it's it's just it's just very strange
now
that we're almost two months removed
from
their last game
uh whatever seven eight weeks whatever
it is
it's just pretty strange but again he
played for a long time
i guess he deserves the right to do
whatever he wants but it's just it just
seems strange to me
yeah i agree though he does have the
right to decide how he's going to pull
the plug on it if he wants to come back
for another year it makes things more
interesting for us
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports